what the hell is this person doing she's
not dancing and isn't a nervous tic ah
she's seeing her Fitbit yes it's a thing
especially as companies now offer
discounts for those who reach fitness
goals like 10,000 steps a day but let's
get something straight right away we are
in no way encouraging people to cheat
their Fitbit for discounts that's fraud
don't do it but if you want your friends
to think you sport your activewear for
actual exercise here are five ways to
trick your Fitbit one the drill attach
your Fitbit to a drill and then hold
down the trigger and not much as they be
on that kind of entrancing though to
attach your Fitbit to your dog and set
the little devil loose just be sure that
your dog isn't lazy as hell
looking at you Lilly 3 whiskey kill two
birds with one stone while making your
favorite dessert and if that's too much
work don't forget about your handy
KitchenAid 4 throw it on a fan and watch
it go around its deceitful and hypnotic
5 pull up your grandma's favorite
rocking chair and rotate your wrist
while kicking back that's it you deserve
a break from all that hard work